hey guys welcome back to Brandon your
video were back on apex legends again
and today we're gonna be talking about a
new leak that just came up on the apex
legends subreddit talking about one of
the heroes that we've talked about
recently in the past couple videos of
ours and of course all over the
community a hero or a legend that that
has been leaked a lot his name is octane
his stuff got leaked this could be faked
this could be true so we're gonna talk
about it give our thoughts so as always
like the view if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new I cover the informational
side of apex legends that being the
updates the new legends the new battle
paths the new challenges anything like
that I will be covering if so if you do
not want to miss an update deftly stay
subscribe to the channel but that guys
let's get started so two things to get
out of the way real quickly I do
apologize for my voice it is 7:00 in the
morning when I recorded this I well I've
on three hours of sleep right now this
is a pain in the ass why am I doing this
I don't know I should be in bed but I'd
rather be doing a video anyway I love
you guys but as well credit to child's
play or I believe that is child's play
on reddit or Twitter or whoever this
happens to be I'll leave the link to the
right of post in the description down
below of course if you want to check
that out which I'll get to in a second
but credit to him because this is the
guy that I believe posted it and as well
I will not be showing this image on
screen because potentially if this is
true I do not want to get copyright
strikes by respawn so if you do want to
see the picture of what I'm talking
about you can check the link in the
description there really isn't much it's
just kind of the abilities and what part
of the character looks like so nothing
too crazy you're not missing much but
you could still check it in the
description if you want now that's all
let's get into the introduction first up
we have octane and he's the high speed
daredevil kind of looks like a robot
after the judging from the robotic arms
in the bottom he also looks like he's
wearing like cargo shorts or something
so it's kind of interesting his passive
is called Swift mend while not taking
any damage he restores health over time
for his tactical is called the
adrenaline junkie moves 30% faster for 6
seconds it costs 10% of his health and
he's immune to slows while active which
most likely probably means that when you
do pop this ability you are gonna take a
little bit of your health Andrew in
regards to getting more speed and
whenever you're hit by the arc star
which gives you that slow ability that
will not be the case anymore
and probably the others like
ultimate and stuff like that and then
his ultimate is called Launchpad
deployable jump ad that catapults users
through the air very straight and simple
especially if you played fortnight you
understand what a jump pad is so that
shouldn't be too hard now going over if
this is real or fake a couple of people
in the comments have been stating that
this could possibly be fake this could
possibly be real
it looks very believable one of the
things that someone told is that there's
very specific numbers on what this
person is showing within this screenshot
or leak and none of the characters in
the game have actual specific numbers so
that could be a little bit misleading
I personally believe this to be fake I
always try to go into every single leak
assuming that this is never going to
happen but whenever I look at these that
kind of give it my my own opinion in
thinking if it was in the game how would
this happen and personally if Upton
actually did release with these
abilities I feel like this would be fine
10% health cost
I believe that's completely fine for the
adrenaline junkie but according to some
guy ez why in the comments he stated
that Bangalore is passive ability which
is the one that makes her run faster she
gets a 25% speed boost for two seconds
while octane over here gets 30% speed
boost for six seconds so I believe
that's a weight a lot more than what
Bangalore is getting so that's gonna be
some speed demon [ __ ] and getting a lot
of momentum which is calm which is cool
to see one guy and Retta also believes
that this is extremely fake for multiple
reasons for example they went into the
store and then went to the legends tab
to actually look at all the abilities
and the person stated well if that's the
case why couldn't they just go into the
legends to have and show it with all the
other legends or could they not have
added that during the photoshop when it
was fake too this was also leaked like a
week ago or so but it hasn't there
hasn't been like any traction on this
photo until recently so why is this the
case and way more other things like the
battle past tab showing up at the top
but there's no information at all
regarding it so it's very interesting to
see yeah but let me know your thoughts
on these guys in the comments below
I feel like passive mentor is passive
but it called Swift mend I feel like it
isn't actually as overpowered as we
think respawn has dealt with tons of
other abilities in multiple games and
stuff and they made the
they've made these other eight legends
pretty damn balanced so I think they
understand that being able to heal up
over time while not in combat is a
little on the overpowered side so
they're probably going to dumb down the
amount of health you actually get and
how much time it is which is pretty nice
I think the adrenaline junkie is easily
his best type of ability just because
it's a lot faster than Bangalore it's a
lot longer yes he does cost some health
but if he's not in a fight he can
probably heal that health back pretty
quickly which is pretty which is a nice
combo I just realized and then of course
the launch pad I actually do like this
idea a lot something might think it's
redundant because we have balloons both
balloons are in fixed positions whereas
launch pads you could probably put these
down wherever you please and they'll be
really nice to see maybe get up to a
high rock and then it maybe if you're in
between like a crevasse or something you
pop the launch pad jump up over the rock
and then kind of spawn trap the enemies
or anything like that whatever some
weird type of trick shots probably gonna
be shot with that some other cool stuff
I think it'd be pretty exciting to see
some launch pad please yeah like I said
let me near thoughts about octane I
really do think he's gonna be a solid
character if this actually holds up and
it's true I'd be really interested to
see how he plays in the real game be I
like to view if you do enjoy subscribe
before new I come for the informational
side of Apex legends that being the
balance changes that leaks the new
legends the new battle past the
challenges anything like that that comes
up within the game that we would be
covering so you want to be kept up to
date with everything happening in the
world of apex legends definitely stay
subscribe to the channel don't that guys
my to my videos will be on screen if you
guys do want to check that out one that
guy said grace today thank you for
watching the video peace out throw the
rest of your day
[Music]